whether it is good enough will as you
said you know we'll rest with the health
workers themselves but the elected
committees in unison in GMB in the BDA
the CSP the Royal College of Nursing and
have voted today to recommend the deal
as the best that can be achieved through
negotiation so that's an interesting
caveat because what I was going to ask
you is is this in your review a good
deal or just the best deal that was
achievable under the circumstances I
think well I mean you always take these
things in context don't you I mean it
would have been better if we'd had this
level of investment put in the Health
Service this time last year because then
we wouldn't have faced a situation where
so many people left to go and work for
better paid and less stressful jobs
elsewhere
um that said you know we've we've got an
increase of six percent of the pay bill
which is not an insignificant amount of
money and hopefully might go some way to
addressing people's cost of living
pressures and you know help employers
retain staff throughout what's going to
be a really busy summer you rightly say
this obviously has to go to the
memberships who will ultimately decide
but with the memberships looking at this
you know a 5.2 pay rise would they
rightly be disappointed given that at
least one Union the Royal College of
nurses started off wanting 19 percent
quite a lot lower well the joint um The
Joint trade unions aimed to get close to
inflation we wanted an inflation busting
pay increase what we've got if you you
know you're adding Consolidated
increases from last year with a lump sum
which is very very crude maths but you
know broadly the investment is over 10
on the pay bill
um which if if it happened at times when
people were facing their stiff bills
then you know that would have that would
have been uh considerably more helpful
so it is a you know it is a decent sum
of money I have done my level best to
give members a credible choice so health
workers can now decide between taking
further strike action and picking up an
offer I know that you know me and other
trade unions work together to uh to
engage with the government and press for
as much money as we could you know as
much additional investment the lump sum
payments that health staff would receive
if they were to pick this Opera up range
from a minimum of sixteen hundred pounds
just over 1600 at the bottom of the pay
scale most people at the top of band
five so band five is where most of the
registered occupations so occupational
therapists nurses physiotherapists
dietitians where they come in and it
would be two thousand pounds for those
people so a not inconsiderable sum of
money and because we've been able to
negotiate now for the pay rise for the
following pay year people would have the
security of knowing that was in their
pay packets early and applicable from
the 1st of April rather than waiting and
crossing their fingers to see what comes
out of the pay review body in the summer
given that there is no an offer on the
table an improved offer as and and for
all those reasons you outline and given
the disruption that this has by your
Union's own admission calls to the
Health Service is is there no more of a
more pressure more of a moral obligation
on staff to accept this and and go back
to work well I'd say the moral
obligation was all on the Secretary of
State you know all we said right from
the start was that we would rather have
had the opportunity to talk
rather than take industrial action you
know all of the all of the the
paramedics the nurses the healthcare
assistants the cleaners the whole team
of the NHS who you've spoken to during
the course of this dispute all of them
will have told you that they would
rather have their unions in rooms
negotiate this has been hard one members
deserve to have a choice the public
deserves to have a Health Service that
has better investment so trade unions
today are pleased that we have the
opportunity to give them that choice